hello everyone and welcome to this
session of Bitcoin mining my name is
Sarah and I'm part of the simplemente so
let's get started and let's talk about
what is Bitcoin mining so what is
Bitcoin so let's take an example so
there is someone who wants to send five
bitcoins to Rachel now we will see how
this transaction can happen now
bitcoin is based on the concept of
digital currency anyone across the globe
can transfer amount in bitcoin
irrespective of the geography from
anyone to anyone so basically you need
to just open an account on the Bitcoin
network have some bitcoins in it and you
can transfer it either you can purchase
the bitcoins online through some
exchanges or you can mine it so once you
have bitcoins in your account you can
transfer it to someone you want whose
address you have now do you want to know
how this transaction work well this
transaction is done by Bitcoin mining so
we will go deep and understand that how
the Bitcoin transaction works what all
entities are involved behind the scenes
in order to maintain the sanity of the
Bitcoin network and make sure that
whomever you wanted the Bitcoin to reach
to has reached and there is no loss of
Bitcoin in the network and it is a
successful transaction so let's
understand certain basics so what's in
it for us today we need to know what is
Bitcoin we will understand the
underlying technology blockchain so we
will talk about that then we will see
what are the advantages of Bitcoin as
compared to other digital currencies and
other digital technologies then you will
go into the concepts of Bitcoin mining
then what is Bitcoin mining and we will
do a demo on certain aspects of Bitcoin
mining now what is Bitcoin bitcoin is
the first decentralized digital currency
that allows users to transfer money
peer-to-peer without any intermediaries
like banks governments agents brokers
nothing is involved and all this is done
using blockchain technology so as we saw
in our previous example two parties
wants to exchange money transfer money
they don't need an intermediate now
Bitcoin can be used for online purchases
commerce transactions it can be used as
an investment instrument and it can be
primarily used for payments to buy goods
and services now it was created in 2009
it came into existence by a person or a
group of people called Satoshi Nakamoto
now bitcoin helps transferring of assets
faster than regular fiat currencies it
has definitely lower transaction fees
because as it has removed the
intermediaries from between the cost of
transaction also goes down and it is
cryptographically secure it uses
cryptography infrastructure and thereby
the identities of the sender and the
receiver are also secured and entire
transaction is cryptographically signed
and the users information who are doing
the transactions or our part of the
network er is also hidden and secure now
what are the advantages of Bitcoin so it
allows fast and quick peer-to-peer
transactions it is impossible to counter
feat or hack the transactions which are
running on a Bitcoin network and it's an
overall decentralized process there is
no centralized body which is controlling
the transactions or charging a fees in
order to validate the transaction it is
the participants in the decentralized
network who are taking care of the
sanity of the network thereby making
sure that the overall transaction cost
is low all the information is accessible
to public it is available publicly on a
public ledger anyone can go and view the
transactions and the volume of the
transactions happening on the Bitcoin
network and it is a low fee transaction
it is comparatively low to other mediums
and channels through which today digital
transactions are made now what is
blockchain so Bitcoin runs on the
underlying technology of blockchain
blockchain is a public distributed
ledger in which transactions made in
bitcoins or any other digital currency
are recorded in a chronological order so
let's see certain features it is
cryptographically secure sign using your
private key and then shared on the
network with the public key it is
immutable any record or any transaction
added on the blockchain cannot be
modified or altered it is run by a
decentralized system there is no
centralized Authority or the body and
the
actions are toured in containers
aggregated in containers called blocks
so a block is the smallest unit of a
blockchain which records all the
transaction a basic structure of a block
is something like this it has four
fields these are the primary attributes
for block it has something called as
previous hash so the previous hash
attribute stores the value of the hash
of the previous block and that's how the
blocks are linked to each other data
this is the aggregated set of
transactions which are included in this
block so these are the set of
transactions which were mined and
validated and included in the block
nonce so in proof of work consensus
algorithm which is used in Bitcoin nonce
is a random value which is used to vary
the output of the hash value so every
block is supposed to generate a hash
value and nonce is the parameter which
is used to generate that hash value and
the proof of hook is the process of
transaction verification done in
blockchain now hash is the resultant
hash value obtained by passing the
previous hash value the data and the
nonce through the sha-256 algorithm to
generate the hash of this block so this
is the digital signature of the block
which is generated and this is the
basically identity of this block now
sha-256 is a cryptographic hash
algorithm which produces a unique 256
bit alphanumeric hash value for any
given input and that is the unique
feature of this cryptographic algorithm
whatever input you give it will always
produce a 256 bit hash now let's
understand the concepts of Bitcoin
mining what is Bitcoin mining Bitcoin
mining is the process of verifying
Bitcoin transactions and recording them
onto the public blockchain ledger in
blockchain the transactions are verified
by Bitcoin users so basically the
transactions have to be verified by none
other than the participants of the
network those who have the required
hardware and computing power and those
entities are called - who we will be
talking about them later but the point
to be highlighted is
there is nothing like a centralized body
as in case of legacy transactions where
we used to be dependent on a regulatory
or governing body or a bank to make our
transactions go through now in Bitcoin
here any user with mining hardware and
internet access can take apart that kind
of computer can be a participant and
contribute to the mining community
process is solved based on a difficult
mathematical puzzle called proof of work
so every miners job is true all the
mathematical puzzle which is called
proof of work in order to validate the
transaction and earn the reward and all
the miners as they're completing amongst
themselves to mine a particular
transaction the miner who first saw the
puzzle gets the reward now users trying
to tell the puzzle as I said are called
- they are the participants of the
network who have the necessary hardware
and computing power to do all the
transactions to validate the
transactions invalidated they are called
as miners now in order to understand
Bitcoin mining we need to understand
three major concepts of blockchain it is
based on distributed public ledger it
uses sha-256 encryption algorithm and
proof of work is the underlying
consensus algorithm for Bitcoin mining
so distributed public ledger a
distributed ledger is record of all
transactions maintained in the
blockchain network across the globe in
the network the validations of
transaction is done by Bitcoin users
called as - sha-256 now blockchain
prevents unauthorized access by using a
hash function called sha-256 to ensure
that the blocks are kept secured they
are digitally signed their hash value
once generated cannot be altered now as
the key to 56 it takes an input string
of any size and returns a fixed length
256 bit output value and that is the
primary feature of sha-256 encryption
algorithm you give any input it will
always give you a 256 bit output and it
is a one-way function you cannot derive
the input reverse fully from the output
what you have generated and third is the
proof of work in blockchain mining is a
process you
validate transactions by solving a
difficult mathematical puzzle called
proof of work now in order to do that
the primary objective of the miner is to
determine the nonce value and that nonce
value is that mathematical puzzle that
miners required to solve in order to
generate a hash which is less than the
target defined by the network for a
particular block now in the Bitcoin
network users trying to solve
mathematical puzzle are called as - now
the puzzle is solved by varying a nonce
which produces a hash value lower than a
predefined condition which is called as
the target miners verify the
transactions and add the block to the
blockchain when confirmed and verified
as of today the miners who solve the
puzzle gets a reward of 12.5 bitcoins
now once a block is added to the block
thing the bitcoins associate with the
transactions can be spent
so once the block is validated then the
transfer of bitcoins associated with the
transactions aggregated in the block the
transfers are made then from one account
to the another now in order to generate
the hash let's see you use the sha-256
hashing algorithm you define the hash
value if it is less than the defined
condition the target then the puzzle is
deemed to be solved and if not then you
keep on incrementing nonce value and you
repeat the sha-256 hashing function
passing on to the nonce value and you
define generate the hash value again and
to keep doing this process till the time
you get the hash value which is less
than the target now let's take an
example so for example Beyonc wants to
share ten Bitcoin with Jennifer now in
order to do that what will be the steps
so bounce transaction data is shared
with Bitcoin users the miners from the
memory pool the transaction goes and
sits in a memory pool of and mine
transactions so in a memory pool set off
on mind or unconfirmed transactions wait
until they are verified and included in
a new block they remain in that
unconfirmed transaction pool now -
competing to validate the transaction
using
proof-of-work they keep on continuously
polling the unconfirmed transaction pool
they pick up those transactions and
start validating those transactions the
aggregate in a data block and start
validating they start solving the puzzle
the miner who solves the puzzle first
shares his result across the other nodes
the other set of miners now once the
block has been verified the nonce has
been generated then the nodes will start
ranting their approval if maximum nodes
grant their approval the block becomes
valid and is added to the blockchain now
simultaneously the miner who has solved
the puzzle will also receive the reward
in the meanwhile which will be of 12.5
Bitcoin which as of today stands at 98 K
around dollars now the bitcoins the 10
BTC for which the transaction was
initiated now will get triggered and
will get transferred from Beyonc to
Jennifer now let's take a look at
certain facts in proof of work a
predefined condition the target is
adjusted for every 2016 block which is
approximately every 14 days and an
average time to mine a block is 10
minutes so basically the target keeps
automatically adjusting itself to keep
the block generation within the 10
minute time frame so this is the
representation so in order to keep the
time frame for block generation within
10 minutes the target keeps on adjusting
itself now the difficulty of the puzzle
changes the target changes depending on
the time it takes to mine a block so
this is how a difficulty of a block is
being generated it is the hash target of
the first block divided by the hash
target of the current block so this is
the difficulty which has been changed
after every 2016 blocks so basically it
is very hard to generate the proof of
work but it is very easy to verify by
the miners so once you have told the
puzzle and you have broadcasted that yes
you have earned you have validated a
record you have determined the puzzle
for other miners it is very easy to
verify what you have done and once they
give their consensus the majority then
the block gets validated and gets added
to the blockchain
now since the difficulty depend
on the hash target its value keep on
changing after every 2016 blaack as i
said and as you can see in due course
from the day of inception of bitcoin in
2009 till today difficulty has increased
exponentially and it has been increasing
and thereby the entire effort of mining
and the computing power is also
increasing so as of what it was the
resources which were required to do
mining in 2009 you require more hashing
power more computing power in order to
do the mining today now what if someone
tries to hack the data so let's see
blockchain is a chain of blocks ABC now
each block has solved a puzzle and
generated a hash value of its own which
is its identifier now suppose a person
tries to tamper a block the block b and
tries to change the data which is
aggregated in the block so if the data
of the block will change the hash value
which is the digital signature of the
block will also change thereby it will
corrupt the chain which is subsequent to
it basically the blocks ahead of Block B
will all get dealing because the
previous hash value of Block C will not
remain valid so in order for the hacker
to make the entire block chain valid for
the block B which he has changed he has
to change the hash value of all the
blocks ahead of Block B which will
require huge huge amount of computing
power which will be next to impossible
so as you see the results in the
following block being invalid so with
this whole thing the blockchain is
making sure that the entire sequence
remains non hackable and prevent data
modification now let's see what are the
underlying hardware requirements for
Bitcoin mining and how the hardware is
involved so in the early days miners
used to solve the puzzles using regular
processes the controlling processor unit
CPUs now but it used to take a lot of
time for mining though the difficulty
levels were low but still it used to
take a lot of time now as I said the
difficulties level keep on changing and
growing so the miners also had to
increase the processing power so this
discovered that graphical processing
units GPUs proved to be more efficient
than
regular CPUs so but this also had a
drawback of consumption of electricity
so any miner who has to calculate the
return on investment on the hardware he
also has to accommodate the cost of
electricity and other resources which
are going in in order to do the mining
so finally as of today they are using a
hardware called ASIC
application-specific integrated circuit
which was specifically introduced so
mining which consumes less power and has
a higher computing power and a better
hardware for my me so miners are
profitable when their cost of resources
to mine one block is less than the price
of the reward they receive so definitely
they have to have the investment less
than the reward what they own so as of
today in blockchain miners use their
resources to verify a transaction they
each time a block is mined new bitcoins
are created in the network so the
Bitcoin total supply is limited it is at
21 million dollars approximately 21
million bitcoins are in supply 17 to 18
million bitcoins have already been mined
so only 3 to 4 million are left as of
today a reward of 12.5 Bitcoin is given
to the miner on doing the transaction
verification but the Bitcoin mining
reward goes by the huffing principle the
reward given to a miner is half every
210,000 block which is approximately
every 4 years so then after that
threshold is reached the Bitcoin reward
will go down to six point two five
bitcoins so let's take an example of a
lottery ticket where your chances of
winning is difficult so we are talking
about what is Bitcoin mining pool your
chances of winning the lottery is
difficult but in a community if
individuals by multiple lottery tickets
and pool their tickets together then
this will increase their probability and
chances of winning more so suppose
you've won the lottery then based on the
contribution the reward is distributed
among all the participants Bitcoin
mining pool is a similar thing it's a
process where multiple nodes share their
resources together to mine a block now
when a block is solved the miners split
the reward equally based on the amount
of processing
power they have invested so it takes the
pool members to generate a final hash
value then it takes how much amount of
work was contributed by each pool member
and as a result the Bitcoin reward gets
distributed proportionally amongst the
participants now let's take a look at a
demo on how can you see what is the
Bitcoin reward now this is a actual
block of the Bitcoin network as you can
see this is a block and this is the
block reward 12.5 Bitcoin so this was a
block which was mine this is the block
number and these are the set of
transactions which were part of this
block now once this block was mined by
the miner all these transactions can be
done these are the transfers of Bitcoin
from one account to the other this is
the nonce which was generated by the
minor or the mining pool in order to
mine the block and these are the other
attributes and if you take a look at
this URL this is an example of a mining
pool it's a demo account where the
participants have shared their mining
resources and they are mining it in a
pool and see this is the reward for
which they are mining this is the
unconfirmed reward this is the confirmed
reward this is what they have already
validated and this is what they have
earned so far so these are the hash
these are the block numbers which they
have mined so what are the key takeaways
today we learn about what is Bitcoin
what is blockchain the underlying
technology of Bitcoin what are the
concepts of Bitcoin mining how can you
do Bitcoin mining and the demo on
Bitcoin mining I hope you all had a
great session and I'll meet you in my
next session thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here